je trouve ça mal avalé
[Musique]
quoi j'attends les trois cent mille
abonnés huawei
hello la jatte 1 et 3 semblent abonnés
waza d'humeur soir à kiev moi
j'attendais
[Musique]
allô allô c'est bien chagny story by way
j'ai atteint les 300 mille abonnés non 6
mais non si mais non sérieux merci
madame
[Applaudissements]
ce rachat au revoir à los cusi j'ai
atteint les 300 mille abonnés fut non si
mauvaise non y'a voilà
[Applaudissements]
oh
pis
merci à tous pour les trois cent mille
abonnés ont de plus en plus nombreux et
vous êtes de plus en plus géniaux et
aujourd'hui je vous propose de faire le
world business voisard toi qui regarde
cette vidéo fait un waza complètement
épique en string de bain ou tout nu sur
ton toi film le met la vidéo sur youtube
et envoie le lien de la vidéo à
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran tu
apparaîtra dans ma prochaine vidéo pour
le world bégaie ouazar encore merci à
tous vous êtes juste géniaux je vous
aime pas